you kind of try to feel like your space
with a bunch of people that you think is
making you happy
megan the stallion fighting back tears
as she speaks out about being shot in
both feet
and her subsequent recovery thank you
all so much because y'all really been
the ones that have been
helping me get through this in an
emotional instagram live on monday
the rapper told fans about the traumatic
experience
i was shot in both of my feet
and i had to get surgery
to get the taken out get the bullets
taken out and it was super scary
earlier this month meg spoke briefly
about the shooting on twitter
and called out the people who were
making jokes about it writing in part
quote
it might be funny to y'all on the
internet and just another messy topic
for you to talk about
but this is my real life and i'm real
life hurt and traumatized
oh lord i think i was gonna cry
but yeah i had to get surgery it was
super scary it was like
just the worst experience of my life
and it's not funny there's nothing to
joke about
it was nothing for y'all to start going
and making up
fake stories about
i didn't put my hands on nobody
i didn't deserve to get shot and do [ __ ]
during her insta live megan also shared
details about the injuries she sustained
and thank god that the bullets didn't
touch bones
they didn't break tendons like i know i
know my mama my daddy
my granny had to be looking out for me
with that one so her family may be
looking out for her in heaven but down
here she has the support of many loved
ones
including beyonce i mean it's kind of
lit
on wednesday the 25 year old rapper
revealed that her savage remix
collaborator
sent her flowers megan shared this pic
of the florals from queen bee on
instagram
and it came with a note that read queen
send you all my love
god bless
800 degrees chefs cuz
back in may e.t caught up with meg who
opened up about making her dream duet a
reality
how did that happen somebody from my
team hit me was like beyonce gonna do
the savage remix i was like what
like like i have been speaking it into
existence like i want to do something
with beyonce i want a song
beyonce but literally after sky blue it
came like beyonce is going to do this
and i was like
and meg's reaction to becoming friends
would be priceless
have you like face timed with each other
have you sent her
like queen bee a flower arrangement
congratulations our song's a smash
beyonce texted me like the next day i
was like oh my god beyonce i remember
like maybe like two or three times like
the next day and the day after that and
i was like
friends with beyonce